despite being out of the national
spotlight the former president
is working to build a support base from
his home in florida
dw sumisomoskanda reports
palm beach florida this is definitely
not washington dc
but it is a growing hub of political
power within
the republican party and that is its
headquarters
mar-a-lago the primary residence of
donald trump
he may not be president anymore but he
is creating a fortress of money
and influence to defend his legacy and
possibly his future
palm beach is one of the wealthiest
counties in the u.s
it has long been a center for
conservatives and republican fundraising
the money is still flowing but
traditional party structures have been
weakened
and a broad group of people are being
drawn in
melissa martz is an attorney and a
republican running for congress
she believes president trump is shaking
up the establishment and making way for
a grassroots movement to people
like her i view president trump as a
strong patriot
i see him as somebody who is sincerely
fighting on behalf of the american
people
and to be aligned with him would
be very important for me in what i'm
doing martz is one of a growing number
of republican candidates and lawmakers
making the trip to the ex-president's
command center
and looking for his support former white
house press secretary sarah huckabee
sanders held a fundraiser here
she's running to be governor in arkansas
south dakota governor christie gnome
came to mar-a-lago too
she might want to run for president in
2024
and remember the former ambassador to
germany richard grinnell
he was at mar-a-lago amid rumors he's
planning to run for governor
of california but how much power does
the ex-president and the growing circle
around him
actually wheeled over the party i do
think we need to take it
seriously but at the same time it's also
laughable right like
it's just more of the crazy circus
elizabeth newman is the co-director of
the republican accountability project
an organization that supports the
non-trump wing of the party
she doesn't believe trump will run again
himself in 2024
she's calling on republicans to take
back the party
it's going to take time to kind of
effectively convince uh the base
and that that at that grassroots level
that there's an alternative
that is healthier and good for the
country and good for the party
that is not donald trump but some might
be difficult to convince
nearly 45 percent of registered
republicans still support trump
more than the party itself these fans in
palm beach still see the former
president
as their undisputed leader so it's hard
to tell which way the tides are turning
and then there are those who are less
worried about the future of the
republican party and
more worried about their city philip
johnson is a lawyer for the group
preserve palm beach and he says his
clients on both sides of the political
aisle
are worried about being overrun by trump
supporters
there is concern that this is going to
be a party in exile
focused on this area he is
it could become a beacon for his more
lawless supporters
this is where he's located and he still
has all this influence in the republican
party
but uh people are gonna people have to
come here to see him and
we anticipate that that that could
quickly
grow out of control residents might get
a respite as florida becomes too hot
president trump will fly to his golf
course in new jersey for the summer
months
he might be doing some fundraising there
but he will surely be back